my Hall of Fame wide receiver at the end
of the set here on the day that Antonio
Brown is celebrating a big fat new
contract with guarantee dollars at the
place he wanted to go he got out in a
way that few players outside of the NBA
can Michael Irvin here on the Rich Eisen
show Howie EV Merritt I'm doing well man
not as good as I turn it around it's
real Brown it's really remarkable right
how it all worked out for Antonio I'd
give you the floor are you surprised at
how it all worked out for Brown I we are
we're witnessing this new thing here
with what players are doing it and I
guess you could call it representing
their own power
I am surprised at how well it all works
out I mean you know I listen how it will
work out remains to be seen I mean you
know your Pittsburgh is much better
football team then Oakland is even
without Antonio Brown and with it with
Antonio Brown being it being Oakland I
call them Oakland being green with the
Raiders they'll be lost Vegas Raiders
but but but poopy knows the way he
orchestrated all of this the way it all
worked out in his favor it's absolutely
incredible I'm from the old school where
when a team had your right to here
you're right you know there was no
social media
so even when two held out ahead of the
uh-uh this fall out with the team the
only person boys got hurt was basically
the team's voice because nobody really
interviewed he'll put you on TV all the
time but social media has scenes that
and he just kept barking and barking
until they got him out well what do you
say to people who think that that is
sending a bad signal well it's business
it's the business of business first of
all let's be real here with with how it
transpired I mean think about it early
on we were talking about it this season
on this ailment when you know the end of
Roethlisberger will call out an Antonio
Brown and he will come in and he would
try to do the company thing he said hey
I
episode is I can take it I can take it
we all looked at each other I want you
to really change it maybe he's just
saying that he was trying to do the
right thing the company thing but that
thing kept going on being came back yeah
I should have thrown all four passes to
do too
you know after a while I guess he just
comes now and and and he couldn't take
it anymore and it has worked out existed
Le'Veon Bell
I thought Pittsburgh sent a bad message
when they didn't a lady on bail right
and then being if you have fog with the
Antonio Brown and the first thing they
do is step up and says we're going to
extend Ben Roethlisberger you know I was
like maybe that's not the time to be
mentioning this when you just let the
other when you add to this issue with
other two guys and you're calling other
guys 52 kids so it so it's all just a
bad situation in Pittsburgh and I think
what they're trying to do is say let's
just get rid of all of the bad
situations you wouldn't start this thing
all back over new and move forward so so
yeah I'm surprised how well it worked
out and and what little Pittsburgh has
gotten back for how much they have given
up its given up one of the best running
backs and one of the best wide receivers
and got 2/3
you know fifth that's incredible when
you think about it in today's games yeah
no rings in the 21 million dollar cap
head to anyone see that's the thing
people have to get on after understand
it this thing where when you have that
much guaranteed money that's why I
always say now engage it's a partnership
with these players you can't just cut
them you can't this really so you know
and of course if they force a trade like
this you're going to get pennies on your
dollar and and that's exactly what
Antonio Brown here he made it such an
issue that they had to trade up and yeah
Pittsburgh loses big time in this
Michael Irvin here on the Rich Eisen
show what are other Pro Bowl all-pro
wide receivers with a few years left on
their deal thinking today Michael Irvin
well I don't know that there's a whole
lot of people first of all there was
only one Antonio Brown you know that
there's only one Julio Jones DeAndre
Hopkins so you didn't do there beckons
you know you those other guys that are
below that they should not try that kind
of stuff that's like this kind of stuff
you know Antonio Brown he's such a
unique talent in such a gifted player
and all of those guys are so what
they're telling you it and what they're
telling you is a yes you guys got to
treat us with some respect here no more
just acting like this that the
quarterbacks are basically throwing and
catching the passes no we're playing and
we're receiving it so we're going to
have to get some respect but but I think
you'll see teams teams better teams are
smart about how they're handling players
you know they're giving those players
that respect I think it just went bad in
Pittsburgh who your loves we're here
DeAndre Hopkins loves where he is and
the owners are the blank and all of
those guys make sure them so told guys
the respect that they deserve and they
don't have these problems and all that
that was not the case in Pittsburgh so
it seems Michael that this is the
contractual equivalent of you telling
those stories out Jimmy Johnson would
treat players differently based on their
abilities well exactly exactly you know
I was shocked honestly honestly arm when
just when when Antonio Brown went on the
interview and said you know that he had
never really set with the owner they
don't they don't talk to him was like
are you joking
Jerry III conversations I've had with
Jerry and everything I mean I just kind
of think that's how it is everywhere and
it's not that way and and I and out of X
people when you give that kind of
service which you know what I liken is
to a horrible divorce you know when you
give yourself so much in a marriage and
then all of a sudden you break up that's
a with the extra whipping we always see
it all the time and any celebrity
divorces everybody's in the paper saying
everything everybody
the show saying everything about the
next person because that's all ripping
it's been raping ripped apart and all
the bad stuff comes out and Antonio
Brown forced that divorce because all
the bad things that were said to him
while he was in the marriage he forced
himself out of the marriage and went
right back to the altar and said I got
me a real pretty girl I married her
again right there today with a bigger
contract I mean it was it's amazing to
watch the power and it is say what you
were originally love what we do but that
was the power of social media that's
what it does now yeah I asked that a
Drew Rosenhaus before if he thought that
if tio had social media back in the I
guess sit up on the lawn days that he'd
have gotten contracts that he wanted
back in the day and I'm wondering if you
think that it would work doing his sit
up in the driveway he can spin his own
Meredith he was going to sit up in the
driveway with everybody on TV
it spun the narrative so and then hold
oh it was because it's dry with what
appeals to the driveway on it so season
I'm good ready almond picture a big
chest whatever I Tonio Brown sir okay
ready for my next game and he's talking
in a bad way towards his old team
he's spinning the narrative and
everybody's listening what he's saying
you know it's not just some new station
or some TV station or even a radio
interview is picking and choosing what
to claim he's getting the plane what he
wants to play all the time it's amazing
it's amazing I started to think about
what it would have been if if we were
there social media back in the day all
right so while we're spitting truth here
michael irvin how much pressure does
this put on Big Ben in Pittsburgh you
know that's what do you want us why I
got rid of Todd daily because they I
guess they were all trying to control he
wants to throw the ball and he wants to
be the leader
and now he'll get that opportunity and I
do believe it puts pressure on him to
win football games now that he's got
nada both of those guys are gone
both lady on in Antonio Brown are gone
and he's there by himself he is the true
leader with those 52 boys or 52 kids
just just incidentally I just just bet
that kind of what was going I believe
most African Americans hurt - when you
say 52 kids 52 more same thing just to
making that kind of a statement and I
think that that did kind of lend some
credence to what Antonio Brown was
saying about what's going on their
organization iiiii can't wait I can't
wait to see how this thing plays out on
the football field on the football field
next year for the Pittsburgh Steelers we
Cleveland coming up like they're coming
up so you Baltimore won the division
last year ah but this is going to be
interesting to see enough they don't
make a playoff next year again some job
if we such odds in jeopardy in
Pittsburgh well I do want to say this
Kevin Kolbert in his second time around
at the combine - to explain what he
meant by 52 kids said he was just
referring to the fact that Ben's been to
the Super Bowl and he's the grown up and
he actually uses the phrase kids and has
even done so to the face of Marky's
Pouncy and the rest of the guys in the
locker room so I do want to throw that
out there at least to you yeah time that
be heard everybody else thought about it
thoughts about it they go back and try
to clean that up and change it up but
still that was out there that was a
narrative thing still it still does this
thing that you never really see Tom
Brady does it separates the quarterbacks
on the rest of the team that's one thing
boy and guys like Tom never would say
they won't say they don't say all right
guys behind me on leaving though they
say guys come with me we're going
together and that's what separates the
good from the great
that's what I think separates
championship that we talked about being
won championships we didn't hear what
Dan was not the main leader of those
teams that won those Super Bowls that
was Jerome Bettis and
warden knows God and being never called
those guys out he never called our toast
guys so so you know the first is for him
to say that as if being let those teams
were being was just a part of those
teams it and I think that's what the
guys are trying to say now can he become
part of us it still be our leader but as
part of us not as the feet out in front
of us in above us all that's the problem
going on it so a couple more minutes
left with you Irv juju Smiths Schuster
without Antoniou Brown I know you love
this kid you were pounding the table for
him when we watch my workout at the
combine all the way through obviously to
his breakout seasons to start his career
can he be as successful without Antonio
Brown on the other side of the field
Michael yeah he can't rich rich and
Richard know I love this kid I love
Judge Ronald I said it for the first day
I saw him on when I hit the feeling at
combine I've been told I said this is a
steel start out wherever years are the
number two but he'll grow into a number
one he's been playing like a number one
since he's gotten into me
now there are pressures that come with
being a number one but he has that
mentality he has that work ethic and
certainly has the physical skill set and
yeah I think Chris burgers done a good
job
I like the Washington kids that they
have I think he's a good clear um it's
just a matter about bringing him along
without killing his confidence but
lifting him up especially in his young
stage right now I think you do Wilson
Connors don't have young talent they
still have young talent but a fine
Pittsburgh if I'm owners but on Jim if
I'm talking to being about his
leadership style to make sure you don't
mess up the young talent we have because
they've already heinous you just talked
about rich they seen it Exodus clean
your things don't go right you've
already seen the next it is clean yeah
Washington's only good if he runs
through the route and doesn't just jump
for the ball right Michael I heard that
somewhere
all along go aside on you know just no
tell me how to throw don't you tell the
other kids just make it grow and how
make the church but but that's what
we're talking about it's just about
leading each other in all of these kids
everybody in the NFL a grown you have to
treat them as such if you're asking guys
the crowd you could mix themselves and
give all that they have you got to treat
them as a man or you're going to have
some of the situations that we've had in
Pittsburgh and an Antonio Brown we're
all assuming it's a good fit for Gruden
and the offense correct with car it's
gonna work and people have been calling
Antonio Brown with all kind of dogs and
everything
I won't dogs on my team I won't i won't
go beast on my team and i say if you got
a dog and as long as you got the right
people around I'm coaching that dog and
he knows how to feed him early let him
get us a puppy chow early then he'll be
fighting for you now now now if you
don't see the merlic still biting at you
a dog is a good thing to have as long as
he's fighting for you you just got to
make sure he's not biting it and you can
handle that with your play calling and
how you handle things you know one time
I with the door gorgon Redcliffe a game
that's out so high cool man don't look
at me like I like my job
to what do you think I'm stupid I like
my job I want a scoop I want us to win I
will get you the ball early okay
good over though he knows how to feed a
dog and want dogs on your team and and
I'm sure poodles they have these happy
here's one now I'm sure and so while
we're on story time before I let you go
what's that story about Jimmie Johnson
treating players differently you tell
what's that favorite one about Jimmy
Jimmy always tell you you know and and
I'll tell you this way we had Thursday
nights out Thursday night was always the
night we always go out have dinner hang
out drink as a team and we will go out
when we went out one Thursday night with
in late Friday for the nine o'clock
meeting I walked in late with this clear
how long here late you walk yeah hey
Jimmy looked at me with his little
strategy with hot rich he was hot he
said you might leader 20 get in the
meeting he turns it over places you kick
you kick it out right now on the spot
you cut him on the spot
he walked in the meeting and he
explained everybody there's a difference
there's levels in this if you play up
here are you making mistake I have to
work through those mistakes and I'm
gonna be more need to work through old
mistakes with you but if you're down
here you make I'll get Witter you read
immediately now let's get ready to go to
practice everybody understand in life is
like that if you toss a penny you make
it 15 million you're selling 15 million
dollars a year they're going to work
with you on some situations if you're
selling at about a hundred thousand
dollars
yeah that might be different just go
carefully speaking they might not work
with it's just business that's what he
was explaining to us and Michael Irvin
finishes this interview by proving
always be closing well done thanks for
calling always be close man I'll tell
you that a be absolutely seed there's no
question about it
unbelievable I can't wait for next you
it's going to be interesting where all
that is going on absolutely going to be
a free agent sorely in the fringe and
the frenzy love you ERV be well we'll
chat soon I'll be rolling there
Wednesday I'm sitting here Monday we're
gonna do it from the Rich Eisen show
first hour of the free agency in about
an hour and about 20 minutes from now as
a matter of fact right that's enough
crank it up baby
as Michael er the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on Audie